avec nos invités c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler j casanova
spécialiste en communication bonsoir
gilles casanova merci d'être avec nous
en duplex également pierre tattevin
épidémiologistes chef du service des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes
merci d'être avec nous on dirait que
pierre tattevin tout d'abord gilles
casanova sur voilà l'ensemble de la
locution 27 minutes quand même un
président clairement on le disait avec
nos invités deux précédents un président
en campagne
dans 27 minutes plus théâtral que jamais
le père fouettard nous a raconté un
conte de noël il a la chance de vivre
dans un pays où tout va bien le monde
entier nous envie et d'ailleurs il est
d'accord avec eric zemmour c'est une
pompe aspirante pour les immigrés de la
terre entière un pays qui a le meilleur
taux de croissance du monde 1 mais un
pays qui est maintenant le meilleur dans
tous les domaines et grâce à ce que nous
avons fait ensemble nous mêmes dans
notre bureau à l'elysée comme il l'a
expliqué c'est un rêve qu'on voudrait
partager alors c'est un peu le père
fouettard quand même parce que si vous
avez plus de 65 ans le 15 décembre c'est
fini de rire si vous vous êtes chômeur
et bien que vous n'avez pas exactement
les six mois et bien partir du 1er
décembre c'est fini de rire si vous êtes
dans un secteur où c'est tellement mal
payés qu'on a du mal à trouver des gens
qui veulent bien travaillé et que vous
n'êtes pas du tout ce secteur justement
et que vous hésitez à diviser votre
salaire pour le bc fini de rire aussi
donc on est dans un pays où le bonheur
est total mais se paye d'une certaine
sévérité alors il y à une rénovation
c'est que le système à qr code
passez une étape supplémentaire vous
souvenez la promesse jamais on vous le
demandera pour aller au bar ou
restaurant la promesse jamais il n'ira
au delà du 15 novembre n'y a maintenant
une autre chose c'est que le qr code se
divise en âge en classe d'âge selon
votre classe d'âge vous avez des
obligations ou pas comme il le dit c'est
si simple de vivre libres il suffit de
faire ce que je vous dit de faire
c'est une novation dans la zone arc pays
occidental vous savez moi je ne suis pas
là pour être choqué je suis là pour
décrypter on se rapproche vraiment du
dispositif chinois c'est à dire selon
votre âge selon par exemple vous avez 30
ans et vous n'avez plus tous vos points
est ce qu'il est raisonnable de vous
laisser aller au café boire dans quelque
temps on va nous dire que moins trente
ans il y a tant de morts sur les routes
si vous n'avez plus tous vos points
votre pass va s'éteindre et nous avons
là donc une innovation qui est tout à
fait sérieuse qui va dans le sens de ce
que les consultants américains qui ont
travaillé sur le pass sanitaires ont
fait avec un grand succès pour le
gouvernement chinois mais dans un régime
dont la base n'est pas la démocratie on
va en parler justement avec notre
épidémiologistes mais je vous propose
tout d'abord d'écouter mêmes macron sur
ces restrictions et sur ce pass
sanitaire
même si je sais combien cela est
difficile le port du masque à l'école
sera donc pour le moment maintenu
l'application des gestes barrières qui
protègent autant contre le coc vide 19
que contre les maladies contagieuses de
l'hiver doit aussi faire l'objet d'une
attention accrue
nous avions tous un peu relâcher nos
efforts et c'est bien normal il faut
donc les reprendre les contrôles pour
l'application du pass sanitaires dans
les établissements concernés et pour les
entrées dans les ports les aéroports les
gares seront renforcés et nous
continuerons comme nous avons toujours
fait à adapter nos décisions territoire
par territoire en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie tiens ça
demain renforcement des contrôles
évidemment on va parler avec vous de
cette fameuse troisième dose parce que
c'est ce qu'il y a certainement depuis
notable ce soir on vient d'entendre
gilles casanova sur l'aspect
respectives sur ce que ça veut dire d'un
point de vue politique mais vous le
médecin vous êtes plutôt un médecin
soulagé satisfait ce soir c'était
nécessaire
mais je crois d'avoir insisté sur la
troisième dose c'est vraiment très
logique on commence à avoir des études
notamment qui viennent d'israël qui a
été un peu plus précoce que nous sur la
troisième dose et qui montre que hong on
a des taux d'anticorps après la
troisième dose qu'ils sont bien
meilleurs qu'après la deuxième dose donc
on se retrouve dans une situation qui
ressemble un peu à la vaccination des
enfants où on fait une primo vaccination
pour en force un an après et ensuite on
peut espérer que ça va durer longtemps
mais ça veut dire en gros puisque
emmanuel macron le rappelle a aussi
ouvert la campagne aux 50 64 ans à
partir de début décembre ça veut dire qu
en clair dans trois mois ça va être
généralisé à cette catégorie d'âge et
ainsi de suite on va plus en sortir
ça veut dire que ça va être généralisé à
toute la population à peu près à coup
sûr mais c'est logique de commencer par
les plus de 65 ans puisque c'est eux qui
ont les anticorps et des globules blancs
un peu moins solide du coup qu'ils
eurent un peu moins longtemps et c'est
comme ça que je comprends le fait que le
pass and i ter soit
imposée avec la troisième dose que pour
les plus de 65 ans à partir de 15
décembre parce que c'est eux qui ont la
possibilité d'être vaccinés d'ici là
mais cette logique là risquent de
conduire au passage et air conditionné
par la troisième dose pour à peu près
tout le monde quelques mois plus tard
quand tout le monde aura pu se faire
vacciner et or a pu avoir accès à ces
deux troisièmes
2015 à novare on a vu plusieurs
réactions tout à l'heure on va peut-être
les revoir d'ailleurs télégramme
évidemment beaucoup de téléspectateurs
s'inquiète de cette obligation qui dit
pas son nom c'est pas la première fois
qu'on a ce débat emmanuel marc comprend
clairement un risque politique à six
mois de la présidentielle
il a choisi une voie
sévère mais après tout quel est son
propos son propos est d'être le premier
à l'issue du premier tour ensuite c'est
terminé puisque il pense que les
sondages lui dise qu'il aura en face de
lui des personnes dont les positions
sont suffisamment extrême pour que des
tas de gens finissent par voter pour lui
ou ne pas voter et le laisser passer
donc il n'est pas du tout dans l'idée de
conquérir les français si vous étiez à
sa place afin de faire vous dit
aucunement besoin il n'a aucunement
besoin de convaincre les français les
soins les 59 % de français qui ne
veulent pas qu'il se représente ne
l'intéressent pas pas du tout il n'a
rien à leur dire leur opinion et déjà
fait son propos c'est de maintenir
autour d'une vingtaine de points il sait
très bien que les 24 points dont il est
crédité sont très au delà de ce qu'il
pourra voir dans les urnes mais s'il
réussit comme jacques chirac en 2002 à
avoir un peu plus de 19%
quand les autres sont entre 10 et 15 il
est assuré comme jacques chirac en 2002
d'être élu président donc il a une
politique très rationnel qui est
enveloppée dans un discours très
théâtral comme souvent chez lui vous
avez trouvé extrêmement théâtrale cette
voix justement tout le monde en a parlé
ce soir
grippé le président ou où il feint la
théâtralité je pense que comme chez tous
les comédiens il ya un moment où l'on
sent qu'on a atteint sa maturité et
qu'on va pouvoir aller plus loin
attaquer des rôles plus difficile dans
le répertoire je pense que c'est cela
autre satisfaction du président se soit
on n'a jamais autant investi dans la
santé en parlant des revalorisations
chez les soignants est ce que vous vous
partager cet optimisme des manuels mc
ren
non parce qu'on a tous été plutôt déçus
par le
l'étendue de ce qui a été proposé pour
la revalorisation des soignants elle
savait que parmi les pays d'europe on
est un des pays où les soignants
notamment aux côtés infirmiers aides
soignants ont des moins bien payés donc
il y avait un retard important qui a été
en partie comblé mais vraiment que mon
parti donc nous on ne peut pas avoir un
satisfecit sur cette partie là
clairement j'ai casanova a enlisés à un
président en campagne qui dit pas son
nom une france quasiment in et à l'idéal
on a vu
un pouvoir d'achat augmenter selon lui
70 euros pour les jeunes les moins
favorisées par mois la violence qui
baisse
qui croire quand on voit certains
chiffres qui nous disent le contraire
écoutez il faut croire au bonheur c'est
le discours d' emmanuel macron pensée
printemps avait il dit pour se faire
élire en 2017 il faut croire au bonheur
c'est son discours d'aujourd'hui je
pense que les français n'ont pas la
chance de vivre sur la même planète que
lui et donc ce sont les français qui se
trompent vous pensez comme moi
merci en tout cas gilles casanova merci
pierre ta doivent avoir été avec nous et